That's okay eh no no no it's okay to come to TV to release these things
people have died out of misery because people have to accept jobs of
misery with conditions of misery and your son is telling you that it was
the only salary that came into his house and to get the family out what
happens that no one has to sweep this lady has had to be There and that
no one has to sweep in 1 company no one sweeps in compliance with 1
company that does not comply with the law of
labor preventions that does not comply,
that does not comply with anything and that the city council
of Madrid is ashamed to give the CEO of this company the merit.
The medal of merit of the City is 1 shame no no no no man people no yes what a
scream I scream no no no no I scream because you are the voice of the
oppressors you come here to defend the oppressors no no no you come to defend
the oppressors and those of us who are oppressed have to scream because
otherwise we are never heard we are never heard forgive you the unions are
telling you they are not they can negotiate nothing because the salaries are
pocket because the people who go there forgive of course that the salary has
to do with it because when you have no other salary of life than this one who
is in the sun you have to be putting up with and swallowing 1 lot of things of
course and this poor gentleman has had to swallow he has had to swallow that
nobody picks up the fruit you eat yes sir that nobody builds the law you go
out with the law then nobody that nobody does anything nobody do anything that
everybody stays at home and nobody works you neither what we have to ask is
that certain hours there are people who are working in the street neither he
nor the firefighter in the street no no clear no no the firefighter what has
been put in the fire clear the firefighter the firefighter no no no clear to
the firefighter to give no no to the firefighter to be paid as he has to be
paid he is charging €1 000 and you shut up and you shut up and you shut up no
man no the heat is the same no the heat is not the heat is not the same
because if you go for a walk no ma'am no little no ma'am no ma'am because the
heat is not the same if you are walking down the street that if you are
working ah no to 40 degrees to 40 degrees of heat man stop telling stories
it's enough to tell stories man eh you're not going to come and tell stories
on TV ok ok it's up you're so hot you escorted 1 son you go for a walk man
it's Claudia Roger you'll say it you that I go for a walk man of course you go
out for a walk you go for a walk you go for a ride you go out to bite on the
ground no no I don't go out I don't I'm not like that from the street shut up
you shut up you shut up you shut up and I don't want to shut up either and
I'll scream and scream because you only come here to defend the roll of the
rich and the capitalists what do you say man what Rico and capitalist is what
all the rich do the Rich will be you I'm not Rico I'm not Rico either but
Montse ok you are and I'm Rica man beat him up to defend the rich please,
you are already messing with 1 poor man to say man will not have died
because of course people are dying of heat sorry man has died of heat
because he was working and when it is 40 degrees yes and you are doing
some gendillos and the teacher in his house was working watering the garbage.